now to this big story a deadly plane
crash created a frightening scene in a
southern California neighborhood flames
and thick smoke poured out of a home in
Yorba Linda yesterday after part of the
plane slammed into the building four
people inside were killed along with the
pilot two people escaped from the home
but were injured Carter Evans is in
Yorba Linda southeast of Los Angeles
near the crash scene part of good
morning good morning this is all blocked
off here preserved for NTSB
investigators now the plane crashed into
a home down the block but it apparently
started breaking up while it was in the
air debris is everywhere you could see
it did some damage to this home
witnesses say it felt like an earthquake
when the plane hit the ground flames
erupted from this two-story family home
in Yorba Linda Sunday afternoon after
part of the plane and one of its engines
slammed into it I heard a huge explosion
the planes body was found in a backyard
of another nearby home plane parts
rained down across the neighborhood this
video shows a man using a garden hose to
put out a fire on a wing friends house
leaked down the street I'd lick that
parts of the engine flew into their
house a new roommate
according to the NTSB the twin-engine
Cessna 414 took off from Fullerton
Municipal Airport around 1:35 p.m. it
made a left turn and climbed to about
7,800 feet about 10 miles into the
flight the plane began a rapid descent
into the neighborhood home surveillance
video appears to show part of the plane
falling from the sky I love this huge
piece police say two men and two women
inside the home were killed along with
the male pilot they've been homeowners
there for probably close to 40 years
Daniel you Gul D says his longtime
family friends were among the victims
they cared for their neighbors and for
friends and family and that they will be
truly truly missed the Gauley says the
homeowners were holding their annual
Super Bowl party yesterday but most
people were still on their way to the
home when the crash happened
Gail such a terrible story that's the
last thing you think will happen to you
in your home thank you very much Carter